be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
the crossovers are a major part of the
comic-book industry and they have been
for quite some time the first crossover
between traditional comic book
characters which is to say everybody
after the creation of Superman came in
june in august of nineteen forty when
name of the Submariner met Jim Hammond
the original Human Torch
four months later DC followed suit with
the introduction of the Justice Society
by Gardner Fox and for the next 70 some
odd years crossovers played a huge role
in not just expanding the comic
landscape but offering ways to beef up
existing stories case in point in 1952
Batman and Superman met for the very
first time up until that point they had
never met each other and in fact there
was no indication in their stories that
the two actually existed in the same
universe the only indication of the only
mention of Superman in a Batman story
and vice versa was that they were
advertising for a Superman story or
Batman story in the other's respective
comics but up until the creation of this
particular story of Superman issue
number 76 a shared universe didn't exist
well suddenly after Batman and Superman
met one another and revealed their
identities to one another well now
Wonder Woman was crossing over an
Aquaman was crossing over then everybody
was crossing over in 1961 DC crate of
the multiverse for the flash of two
worlds storyline and then we had this
huge multiversal expansion of all these
different characters from all these
different types of realities different
versions of the most popular characters
and it was a huge hit now granted this
amalgamation in combination of varying
stories and characters from across the
landscape resulted in a lot of confusion
hence the reason why crisis on Infinite
Earths happened in 1985 but the fact
remains the crossovers played a major
role in the comic-book industry in the
1960s when spider-man received his first
solo series after appearing an amazing
fantasy issue number 15 and a handful of
subsequent comics he literally went to
the Fantastic Four and tried to join
their team now of course he was turned
down
but because the Fantastic Four were so
popular the Fantastic Four as a team was
used to try to launch other teams and
characters into popularity if their
titles were not succeeding the Inhumans
were introduced in the Fantastic Four
the early runs of the x-men under Roy
Thomas and Stan Lee and Jack Kirby they
were crossed over into the Fantastic
Four because you early x-men stories
were not succeeding there was
there was a reason behind why these
things were done there was motivation
designed to expose fans to concepts in
comic books that they would never have
seen before
now is the 1980s turned into the 1990s
we began to see more crossovers among
various teams but they were usually
confined within a singular landscape for
example the mutant massacre the fall of
mutants these storylines from the x-men
universe were confined to the x-men
universe but they featured the original
x-men team now called x-factor crossing
over with the new x-men team of
Wolverine storm Colossus and I collar so
on and so forth and those were huge hits
what has time progressed again we
started to see more and more things
coming out of this of course the
Avengers function as a crossover of
source where the Avengers was its own
self-contained stories of popular
characters within comics it really
wasn't until we began getting into the
1990s that crossovers began to take this
turn towards the realm of absolute
pandemonium the first instance that I
cite is the Age of Apocalypse and the
second is the onslaught saga the Age of
Apocalypse is well known by most people
as being an instance where by the son of
Charles Xavier a mutant named David
Haller also known as Legion traveled
into the past to kill magneto
under the belief that he would make his
father's life easier if magneto was dead
David Haller travelled into the past
Charles Xavier jumped in front of the
blast dying in the process apocalypse
seize the opportunity to take control of
the world altering reality for the next
six months now in the onslaught
storyline this came out of fatal
attractions it came out of an existing
x-men crossover storyline involving
Magneto and his acolytes asteroid M so
on and so forth Wolverine having the
adamantium torn out of his body but once
that was done by magneto once he ripped
the adamantium out of Wolverines body
the result was that Charles Xavier
literally just shut his mind down well
the side effect of this was that the
frustration Charles Xavier felt with
humanity's unwillingness to accept
mutants and work alongside mutants
niggled with Magneto's hatred of
humanity spawning the psychic entity
that literally laid waste to the Marvel
landscape now at the time these stories
were cool because the 90s was a time of
high-octane fast paced stories and these
fell right in line with that ideology
that's why a lot of people look at them
as a perfect indication of
in the 1990s it's exactly what comics
were about back then but Marvel didn't
let go of that trend Marvel never moved
away from that in the 2000s a guy named
Joe Quesada came in and he said we need
to revamp everything we need to change
everything
Marvel's not classic Marvel any more we
need to get it back to its roots of
being a classic company that tells
stories that are relatable with
identifiable heroes and make things the
way they used to be so what do you do he
literally spent 10 years engineering
crossovers the House of M decimation
Civil War Dark Reign siege all these
stories exist as major crossovers
designed to effectively retcon the
history of characters and Marvel Comics
over a 10-year period now the problem
with this is that people that sit down
and they look at crossovers and they say
these are designed to help me recognize
characters that I enjoy it takes away
from that it removes that crossovers
serve the purpose of reminding us as
readers that there's a bigger world out
there that it's not just spider-man
fighting in New York it's not just
daredevil or the Punisher or Luke Cage
in Hell's Kitchen New York that there's
a massive universe out there waiting to
be explored all kinds of things going on
that's one of the incredible concepts
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
people tend to forget well you've got
civil war going on but while Captain
America and Iron Man are fighting one
another on the earth and civil war
Thanos is traveling around the universe
capturing the Infinity stones and
anybody who's ever read the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline knows that in the
Marvel movies all hell is going to break
loose when infinity war comes around but
I digress
the issue that Marvel faces now when it
comes to the realm of crossover stories
is that they've lost their purpose it's
no longer about introducing us to new
characters it's no longer about telling
us there's this great big huge world out
there don't forget yes we've got the
Avengers as a team but we've also got
all these characters and maybe just one
guy gets his hands on a cosmic cube
maybe just one guy gets his hands on the
Infinity Gauntlet and suddenly this no
one is elevated to a cosmic a universal
level threat that everybody has to deal
with and that's what makes crossover so
great now these crossovers are just like
hey guys sales are slumping we've got to
do something let's just have the
Avengers fight the x-men whatever it
makes sense it'll sell and it does sell
but what it also does is it takes away
from the value of crossover events
to the point when people look at comic
books as a whole and they say well I
don't care about crossover events
anymore because I see them all the time
I don't care about this one particular
character's story anymore because
they're not relatable to me anymore I
don't really care what's going on in
comic books because they're not doing
anything that I haven't seen before now
whether or not this is going to be
something that'll get fixed I don't know
but for right now the event fatigue
that's circulating around the internet
the individuals who are tired of these
major crossover stories are beginning to
lose interest and Marvel Comics now I
don't mean to stir up this great big
huge Marvel vs. DC debate I was
literally raised on Marvel Comics but DC
doesn't write character events it's
literally just character events one of
the reasons why Scott Snyder's Batman
was so good is because it was not until
endgame that you even saw anything
involving the rest of the Justice League
Superman never showed up
Wonder Woman never showed up none of
those characters ever made a single
appearance in any of the stories save
maybe one or two times on the whole it
was literally just Bruce Wayne learning
about how a group called the court of
owls had been running everything behind
the scenes in Gotham City for damn near
300 years and he never knew about it how
he deals with that the next stage was to
reintroduce the Joker in the new 52 as a
more sadistic darker version of the
Joker that we had known in the 1990s
Scott Snyder did a beautiful job with
that story and the trend continues
Aquaman Wonder Woman Superman the Green
Lantern cyborg if he really matters is
always the same thing character based
story arcs and it gives us a reason to
come back because the question is what's
going to happen to this character next
yes they may cross over in the pages of
the Justice League yes there may be some
great big huge planetary wide event but
it doesn't happen all the time it
doesn't happen three or four times a
year it happens once a year maybe maybe
it'll happen twice a year but it won't
happen that frequently so again this is
just my ranch this is my little spiel
about crossover events and comic books I
really hope he gets taken care of as
time progresses maybe it will maybe
alone I don't know but I'll catch you
guys later peace